翻訳: Kyoko Kamura
校正: Hiroko Kawano
皆さんこんにちは
気難しいはずの
物理学者の肥山と申します
今日は物理という
気難しいお話をやめにして
皆さんに分かりやすいお話をしたいなと
いうふうに思っています
皆さんこう思いませんか
世の中には
常識とかけ離れた突飛な発想から
いろいろな面白い
いわゆるブレイクスルーだとか
イノベーションというのが
生み出されるということがあると思います
または逆の発想、逆のアプローチから
いろいろなブレークスルーが生まれる —
イノベーションが生まれると
いうこともあると思います
例えば これは自動車の大量生産です
100年前は —
たくさんのこの 車に人がいちいち移動をして
自動車の部品を組み立てると
いうことを行ってきました
しかしそれでは 非常に効率が悪いです
そうすると次の
逆の発想というのが生まれます
それは 車を逆に動かす
これが ベルトコンベアの始まりです
そうすることによって
今度は人を動かさず 車が動いて
それに人が張り付いて部品を作っていく —
そういうことによって
自動車の大量生産は生まれました
こういうふうに 逆向きの発想というのが
実社会に非常に大きな役割を担います
実はこの逆向きの発想というのは
我々科学の世界においても同様で
いろいろなブレークスルーを生み出します
この話を私の実際の研究を紹介しながら
お話をしていきたいというふうに思っています
今年のノーベル物理学賞は
ブラックホールの衝突からの
重力波を検証するということです
これは実は100年前に
アインシュタインが予言をしていました
今 100年経って この世界で
この検証を目の当たりにするということは
非常に科学者として嬉しいことです
この後に実は
中性子星というもの[が]合体をして
そこから出てくる重力波というのが
検証されました
実は この中性子星そのものにも
大きな謎があります
我々科学者は この中性子星というものに
今 非常な興味を持っています
では中性子星というのはどういうものなのかと
いうことをお話していきたいと思います
私たちのここにいる宇宙というのは
138億年前に
ビッグバンによって生まれました
その後10億年経って
星が生まれます
星の一生というのは 生まれたときに
太陽の実は８倍をバウンダ[リ]ーにして —
限界にして運命が変わります
宇宙のその小さい星 —
いわゆる太陽の８倍よりも
小さい星というのは
その後 白色矮星になって
静かに燃えつきていきます
太陽の質量の８倍よりも大きい星は
その後 超新星爆発をして
星の内部はブラックホールか
中性子星になります
この中の この中性子星というものに
我々は非常に今 興味を持っています
この中性子星が
どのくらいの大きさかといいますと
直径が20キロくらいです
それはここである
甲南キャンパスを中心にして
だいたい三宮の駅まで
届くぐらいの大きさです
そんなに小さな星なんですけれども
実はこの最大の質量は
非常に大きくて
実は太陽の1.5倍もあります
このことは実は 宇宙の教科書には
ちゃんと書いてあって
我々科学者も常識として捉えています
しかしながら
2010年に恐ろしいことが起きました
なんと 教科書を塗り替えると
いうことが起きたのです
それは太陽の２倍の質量が最大の質量であると
いうことが実は分かったんです
このことは我々科学者は
最大の驚きをもって迎えました
皆さんから見ると
1.5から２倍になったところで
何でもないじゃないかっていうふうに
思うかもしれませんけれども
我々理論家は 実はこの常識だと思われている
太陽の1.5倍というものを
実は理論で説明しようと思って
いろいろ努力を積み重ねてきました
でも下手な理論を使うと
簡単に太陽の質量の1.1倍、1.2倍と
いうふうになって
1.5倍までなかなか到達しない —
そういう努力を積み重ねていたところに
2010年 さらにかけ離れた
２倍という値を持ってきたわけです
我々はかなりショックを受けて
未だに覚えてるんですけど
夜も眠れませんでした
我々は この太陽の質量２倍をどうやって
解決したらいいのかということが
非常に大きな関心事として 今まさに
ホットな話題というふうになっています
では この太陽の質量の２倍である
いわゆる中性子星というのは
何で出来ているのかといいますと
読んで字のごとく
たくさんの中性子 そして少しの陽子
そしてハイペロンと呼ばれる —
地球上には存在しない粒子で出来ていると
いうふうに言われています
この研究をするためには
実はインプットとして
この陽子と中性子の間の力
そしてハイペロンと陽子の間の力
またはこの赤と白の間の力というのが
インプットとして重要です
しかしながらこれまでは
実はこの白と青の間の力[について]は
分かってきていました
ところが 赤と青 または
赤と白の間の力というのは
実はこれまで
よく分かっていませんでした
でも 中性子星の最大の質量２倍を
解き明かすためには
どうしてもこの力というのが重要です
ひとつの解決の糸口としては —
ひとつあり得るのは
この中性子星を人工的に地球で作ると
いうことが ひとつ考えられます
しかし 皆さん考えてみてください
太陽の質量の２倍も大きな星を
この小さな地球で作るって
危険だと思いません？
ちょっと間違うと
ブラックホールになるかもしれない
そんなことを科学者は
やってはいけないわけです
そうすると ここでまた
逆向きの発想が生まれます
今度は中性子星そのものを
細かく細かく 小さく見ていきましょう
そうすると 細かく見ていった
最初の最小単位というのは
この陽子と中性子 そしてハイペロン
３つの粒子でできてます
この３つの粒子 もしくは
この４つの粒子というのを
人工的に作るということを考えます
このハイペロンと陽子と中性子でできている
原子核を「ハイパー核」というふうに呼びます
このハイパー核はこの加速器施設
というところで人工的に作ります
この加速器施設で作ったハイパー核を —
理論的にこの構造を解き明かす
ということを行うわけです
この中でハイペロンと陽子と中性子
この ３つの粒子で出来ています
これを我々は
「三体問題」というふうに呼びます
また４つの粒子で出来ているものを
「四体問題」というふうに言います
この三体、四体問題を
理論で解き明かすということを行うわけです
数えられますよね
三体、四体というふうに
しかしながら 三体問題、四体問題を
理論的に解くということは非常に難しいです
これなんで難しいのかということを
次の人間社会を捉えてお話ししていきましょう
例えば 仲の良いお友達同士で 何か
物事を決めようというふうに考えたとすると
気心が知れているので 物事は
比較的簡単に決まるかというふうに思います
けれど そこに１人気難しい人が —
ちょっと好きじゃない人が
例えばやってくると思います
これ 三体問題です
そうすると先ほど決まりやすかった物事が
途端に複雑になってくるということは
皆さん 経験があるかと思います
ここにもう１人また
気難しい人が入ってくるとします
これ 四体問題です
さらに難しくなってきますよね
先ほど 二体問題だったら
決まりやすかったことが
四体問題になったことで
ご破算になるとか
そういうことも経験おありかと思います
実はこのこと
ミクロの世界でも同じです
非常に多体問題になってくると
複雑怪奇になってきます
これを数式で表すと
途端に寝始める人がいるかもしれませんが
このような数式を明かすということになります
この中で この「V」とあるのがインプットで
先ほど言いました「力」というものです
そしてこの式を解き明かして
「Eとψ（ぷさい）」とある記号
これがアウトプットで解き明かすものです
これが 実は実験と比較することが可能です
こういった式をきっちりと解き明かして
Eとψを出すというのが
実は 私の研究の目的のひとつです
こういった問題を解くときに
これまでは この力というものが
確実にきちっと与えられれば
先ほどの式をしっかり解いて
アウトプットを出し
そして実験と比較するということが
これまで できました
ところが実はこの力という
根幹のものができなかった場合
一体どうしたらいいんでしょうか
アウトプットが出せません
こういった問題に
実は突入したわけです
そこで考えついたのが
逆向きの発想です
つまりどういうことかといいますと
私の問題 数式をきっちり解きます
したがって よく分かっていない力というのを
とにかく使って
しっかり解くということをします
で それをアウトプットとして
実験と比較 検討します
そうすることから 実は逆向きに
力に修正を与えることができます
そうしてできた力、信頼できる力を
今度は中性子星の研究というところに
インプットとして与えるということを
思いついたわけです
こういう今のプロジェクトを
行うことによって
先ほど言いました
中性子星の太陽の質量の２倍という謎 —
これを解き明かすということも間もなくと
いうふうに 我々は感じているところです
最後になりましたが
今日お話ししたのは
この逆向きの発想
逆向きのアプローチです
我々科学の社会でも
この逆向きのアプローチを考えることによって
様々な解決の糸口というのが あっという間に
広がるということを経験します
このことは実は
我々科学の世界だけじゃなくて
実社会においても
重要なことだと思います
例えば 皆さんが新しいプロジェクトを
立ち上げるということをしようと思うと
必ず何か問題にぶち当たる —
壁に当たるということは
経験おありかと思います
その壁を乗り越えるときに
正面突破をするとか正攻法でいくことで
たまたまだとか そういうことで
解決するということはよくあると思います
でもうまくいかないことだって
あると思います
そういう時は
ちょっと別の視点で見る —
逆向きの発想で考えてみる
そうしたことで
今まで難しかったことが
あっという間に解決するということは
よくあると思います
皆さんがこれから新しい課題に
どんどん挑戦していくことだと
いうふうに思います
もし壁にぶち当たったときに
思い出してみてください
この逆向きの発想
逆向きのアプローチです
どうもありがとうございました
（拍手）